guilty  yes be shot on sight spent forth in  perpetuity your system is appreciated  and mandatory the real part of the  started million in she is none making  this easy  [Music]  [Music]  damn  [Music]  good morning black reef another day  another death our time looks fun  for everyone else on this island this  place is paradise a never-ending party  we're hunting me is the main attraction  and no matter how I try to escape they  always cut me down  and I'm one stubborn [ __ ]  every loop I'm learning a little more  piecing together the puzzle there's a  target and they all got to die before  midnight  there's just one little snag  you thought it was going to be easy  Julianna Blake black reefs protected and  a real pain in my ass she may kill me a  million times but eventually inevitably  I will break this  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I don't like watching you die I like  killing you his difference